we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we are going to go to our next caller
from the 7 7 4 area code 7 7 4 is always
dicey its central mass it could be Pat's
friends it could could be anybody at 7 7
4 but tell us caller from 7 7 4 who are
you and what's your question today hey
David I love your show I'm Justin from
Quincy I'm volunteering with a group in
Massachusetts called people people
governed not money it's a local chapter
of American promise and we're trying to
overturn citizens united you know
collecting signatures for a ballot
initiative and math it was it would
establish a citizen's Commission that
would develop reports on the impact of
political and election spending and mass
and you know the legal ability of state
governments to regulate core
corporations and and you know of course
this makes the 20th amendment a
constitutional amendment to overturn
citizens united so just wondering what
your thoughts were on that if you
support our efforts and if you do if
maybe you could encourage voters on your
show to sign it before November deadline
yeah maybe host some kind of event or
something like that okay so listen
Justin here worthy causes I'm not
familiar with your organization so I
would not nothing I am about to say
would be an endorsement or criticism of
your organization I'm just not familiar
with it here's what I really want to
know because I talked to folks who are
collecting in fact this weekend I
actually gave a couple signatures for a
couple things when I was out and about
in Boston be as honest with me as you as
you can hear Justin and I know that
you're you know in a role where you are
working on this project do you genuinely
think that this signature collection
initiative that you're participating in
will lead to the overturning of citizens
united I mean in your heart of hearts
tell me because I really do want to
understand because I think it's such a
valuable effort and I support the effort
of course but I've not ever done the
signature collecting thing that you're
doing which is tough right I talk to
people who do it do you genuinely
believe the end result will be the
overturning of citizens united well I I
do think it's a while
Road to that and but the good thing
about this particular initiative is that
it doesn't just focus on overturning
citizens united is that it also you know
tries to increase the word um increase
the what's shown about about
contributions in transparency
contribution transparency I'm sorry with
that you would it increases transparency
about political donate transparency yeah
that's the word I was looking for thank
you yeah
increasing transparency holding you know
are officials accountable in that sort
of way by by having a human presence
listen I totally got that I taught it it
sounds like a worthy cause but my
question was a different one which is is
do you genuinely feel when you're doing
this like this is a good use of your
your limited activism time versus some
other thing well I do think it's a good
use of our time because even if even if
this I I do believe that with if we get
a bunch of different states on on board
with us yeah then then this will lead to
overturning Citizens United but even if
it doesn't do that it does increase
transparency like I said so it has some
positive impact okay very good and
listen I'm being I'm only asking because
I've always felt like these are such
uphill battles and I feel bad for people
out there in the heat collecting
signatures for initiatives that often
are just so overwhelming that they're I
think they're gonna require some other
level of activism although I couldn't
tell you what it is that thing it's not
that I think what Justin's doing is
wrong I don't think what he's doing is
pointless but I genuinely wonder Pat you
know it's it's tough it's an uphill
battle right exactly I mean maybe
collecting signatures is a tough task
and maybe not the most effective way but
that being said I don't know what the
most effective way is yeah actually when
there's already been court cases on it
it's already seems pretty settled right
now yeah all right Justin listen keep up
the good work I hope your work does have
an impact and I completely support the
overturning of citizens united of course
I've been clear about that thanks for
the call